UNIFIED REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
TO PASS MAJOR TAX REFORM AND NOW
THEY FACE A POSSIBLE DACA DEAL.
THE BUDGET.
WHAT IMPACT WILL THE SCUFFLE
BETWEEN STEVE BANNON AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE ON THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
I AM JOINED BY ANN COULTER IN
NEW YORK.
ONE OF THE STRONGEST TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AND NATIONAL REVIEW
EDITOR RICH LOWERY.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
THIS BANNON AND TRUMP FEUD.
WILD LEGAL IMPLICATIONS FOR BOTH
STEVE AND PERHAPS THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM WHICH I FIND
WILD THAT HE MIGHT HAVE SAID
THESE THINGS GIVEN THE APPETITE
FOR MUELLER AND THE DEMOCRATS
TRUMP AGENDA, DO YOU SEE ANY
IMPACT HERE?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO BELIEVE
THE QUOTES.
I HAVE NOT HEARD ANYTHING FROM
BANNON.
THE BOOK REVIEW EDITOR OF THE
"WASHINGTON POST" SAID THERE ARE
THERE ARE A FEW GOOD POINTS THAT
BANNON MADE.
THE STUFF ABOUT RUSSIA IS
SAY THAT.
>> Laura: TREASONOUS AND
UNPATRIOTIC.
>> YES.
>> Laura: I DOUBT THAT SOME 2
BIT LAWYER FROM RUSSIA WAS TAKEN
SAID IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
MEETING, YOU SEND YOUR LAWYERS
IT WAS A STUPID MEETING.
DONALD TRUMP.
THE RUSSIA STUFF IS BORING AND
STUPID TO BEGIN IT.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL HAVE ANY
IDEA WHY TRUMP WON.
I AM STARTING TO WONDER IF TRUMP
AND BANNON HAVE ANY IDEA THAT
TRUMP WON.
THE ISSUES THAT TRUMP RAN ON IS
IMMIGRATION, TRADE AND NO MORE
WARS.
THE TRADE DEALS ARE EASY.
NO MORE WARS OUGHT TO BE EASY.
BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
MEMBER OF CONGRESS RUNNING IN
THAT ELECTION.
TRUMP DIDN'T ENDORSE HIM.
BANNON WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE AT
ON.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
THEY ARE NOT DEBATING
IMMIGRATION.
THE COMMENTS IN THE WOLF
ACCOUNT.
WE WILL LEARN MORE WHETHER THIS
IS TRUE OR NOT.
I AM SURE WE WILL HEAR FROM
BANNON.
RICH, ON THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION
IMMIGRATIO
IMMIGRATION, TONS OF ROOM TO
DEBATE ABOUT THE DACA DEAL.
SHOULD WE HAVE 10 YEARS OF
REFORM?
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS WAS ABOUT.
THIS IS ONE EXERPT FROM A BOOK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE IS IN
THIS BOOK.
I AM SURE THERE IS A LOT MORE.
YOUR TAKE ON THIS ASPECT OF IT?
>> WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
QUOTEED IN THE BOOK WHO ARE
USED THIS NUCLEAR WAR WORD OF
TREASON.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH BLIND
QUOTES WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE
LAST YEAR WHERE BANNON HATES
JARED KUSHNER AND THINKS HE WAS
DOING UNTOWARD WITH RUSSIA.
I HAVE MY RESERVATIONS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT I DO WANT HIM TO SUCCEED.
THE FACT IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BANNON ALIENATED PEOPLE AND
LEAKED AND GOT FIRED FOR LEAKING
WHEN HE CALLED OUT OF THE BLUE A
LEFT WING-JOURNALIST.
AND ALABAMA WAS A DEBACLE.
BANNON IS NOT BACK OFF.
HE CONTINUED TO SUPPORT ROY
MOORE AND GOT DONALD TRUMP
INVOLVED.
FOR DONALD TRUMP WINNING IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
YOU LOOK AT THE LAST MONTH.
BANNON LED HIM INTO A DEBACLE IN
ALABAMA.
MITCH McCONNELL AND PAUL RYAN
PASSED A HUGE PART OF THE TRUMP
AGENDA.
>> Laura: DO YOU FIND IT IRONIC
OR FRIGHTENING THAT THE TAKEN
OR FRIGHTENING THAT THE TAKE
ESTABLISHMENT IS RALLYING TO
DONALD TRUMP?
THAT'S WHY I SAY I WONDER WHY
DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED.
WHY ENDORSE LUTHER STRANGE WHEN
MO BROOKS WAS RUNNING.
BANNON COULD NOT ENDORSE ANYONE
DURING THE ORIGINAL PRIMARY.
IF YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE -- NEITHER
MOORE BECAUSE HE WOULD HAVE
VOTED AGAINST MITCH McCONNELL.
>> Laura: HOW DOES THIS WAR OF
WORDS HELP THE CONSERVATIVE
POPULACE AGENDA?
I SAY IT DOESN'T HELP IT AT ALL.
>> IT DOESN'T HELP IT, BUT I
THINK IT DOESN'T HURT IT.
I THINK IT'S IRRELEVANT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS IMMIGRATION
AGENDA AROUND DONALD TRUMP.
STEVEN MILLER AND COTTON.
THE IDEA THAT STEVE BANNON
PORTRAYED THAT HE UNIQUELY
UNDERSTANDS TRUMP WAS OTHER